forests tend to be naturally spooky
places they are dense with trees letting
in little light and offering plenty of
spots for predatory animals to hide
while stalking their prey prey that
sometimes include humans but life also
thrives there for the Slovak people
there's one spirit that rules it all a
lord of the woods valetti the leshy is a
shape-shifting creature that may appear
human but also takes on the form of the
animals and plants he protects he was
once believed to lead travelers to their
deaths
but could also ensure a successful hunt
he kidnapped young women but kept cattle
from getting lost in the woods he was
feared but also revered the leshi isn't
just some high-level boss in a video but
an important mischievous powerful spirit
that can trace its history back to
ancient religious and cultural beliefs
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
if you've ever been in the woods you
know how scary they can be and how easy
it can be to get lost in one
nineteenth-century text the Leschi is
directly connected to the dangers of the
forest it reads in olden days when
forests were larger and denser than they
are now
the less she used to be constantly
deluding travelers and making them lose
their way and no forest was safe while
Slavic folklore claimed each forest had
its own leshy there could be more than
one territorial disputes between lushy
were said to be the cause of harsh
storms boulders falling or crashing
trees supernatural explanations for real
events most often Alessi appears in its
imposingly tall human guise with long
claws and shaggy hair sometimes with
horns and cloven feet he can grow higher
than the treetops or small enough to
hide behind a blade of grass
the luscious appearance is often
inspired by the vegetation of the forest
with bark like skin and a green beard or
hair which makes sense given that his
name comes from the Russian word meaning
forest less he translates to woods
spirit or wood demon I had the
opportunity to talk to one of my
favorite authors Catherine Arden who's
done a ton of research about Slavic
folklore for her winter night trilogy
most often appears as a Russian peasant
but with some slight slight oddities um
he doesn't hear a belt the left in
Russian is associated with like the
demonic so he crosses his caftan
leftover right
he also inverts his shoes so he wears
his shoes in the wrong feet he doesn't
cast a shadow doesn't cast a shadow and
he carries a cudgel or an ounce like a
weapon and that sort of symbolizes his
authority over the forest alesci may
take on a human form and even disguise
itself as someone its victim knows but
it can inadvertently reveal its true
nature through small mistakes in their
transformation and since he can take the
shape of
thing in his domain unless he may appear
as anything from bears and wolves to
domestic cattle birds a tree even a
whirlwind of beads unless she can also
alter its poise you might call out to
his victims in a voice they recognize or
whistle like the wind blowing through
the trees animal sounds the rustle of
leaves and laughter are also part of his
verbal repertoire but even then used to
confuse and tempt victims he was feared
because he possessed the ability to lead
people and animals astray forcing them
to die from exhaustion trying to find
their way home or misleading them to
fall into a ravine or swamp lushy were
said to be great gamblers playing cards
against one another in other spirit
demons frequently betting their
resources of their particular woods when
huge populations of squirrels suddenly
migrated across the Ural Mountains in
the 19th century some people attributed
it to a Siberian leshi driving his
losses to their European kin the less
she received sacrifices and offerings
from the people in order to secure his
favor in aid in their survival as the
master and guardian of the forest a
huntsman success or woodcutters bounty
was believed to be dependent on the will
of the Leschi
even herdsmen relied on this creature
because of this relationship
the herdsmen were seen as intermediaries
between the human world and the world of
the Leschi the spirit world you could
avoid offending alesci by respecting the
forest not only in terms of taking
resources but in general modes of
deference like not whistling or swearing
and not intentionally harming plans
hunting on certain festival days was
also forbidden to avoid the lessees
wrath laying out the traditional meal
for greeting important guests bread with
salt on a tree stop might keep you safe
from the Leschi this seems pretty minor
but it was and in some slavic country
still is a very important gesture bread
was synonymous with food if a household
didn't have it they didn't have the
resources to eat and salt was a rare
commodity so sharing it expressed
hospitality other protections against
the lushy
included making the sign of the Cross
saying a prayer or spell wearing clothes
backwards or
inside-out retracing your steps out of
the forest or making the lessee laugh so
although Slavic folklore describes them
as antagonistic towards humans by Nature
you can win one over with a little
respect they can actually seemed pretty
reasonable in a lot of ways
unfortunately we can't know the exact
origins of the legend since there is no
record of any Slavic mythology which was
honestly a shock to me many scholars
agree that nothing about the original
Slavic God's creation myths or stories
of their afterlife has survived history
the earliest records of the Slavs dates
back to only the sixth century around
that time the Slavs migrated into other
territories and developed into different
cultures but one of the things that kept
in common is their folklore including
stories of the leshi it's likely oral
tradition played a huge role in this
stories early creation in fact sloths
comes from the proto Slovak Slovenian at
the people called themselves those who
speak with words
however it's speculated that the leshi
was later heavily influenced by
Christianity as Christianity spread
there's also sort of a Christian
explanation which says that volition and
other forest and household spirits were
on angels that were thrown from heaven
after the war between angels maybe they
fell to earth and became horror spirits
or the other one is that spirits like
the lip he's born after the way they
were before it what was once simply a
guardian of the forest became a more
devilish figure this explains some less
she traits like the cloven hooves which
were often associated with evil deities
and Christian stories and even in some
variations of the monster alesci is
created from the marriage of the devil
and a witch or they can be descendants
of Satan's army a hunter or herdsmen
could secure safety and success by
creating a pact with a creature an act I
required renouncing Christian
in some stories lessees recite to appear
in military uniform which may have been
inspired by real fugitive soldiers
hiding in the woods in other cases the
less he has said to approach humans
around a campfire asking for food the
forest did historically serve as a place
of shelter for outliers of society
perhaps the less he asking for food is
an exaggeration of such individuals
looking for assistance
most of what we can study about Slovak
spirits now comes from materials
recorded in the 19th century when
urbanization and advances in science and
education made belief in the
supernatural tenuous nevertheless in
1850s Russian study found that many
peasants claimed to have encountered
alesci personally the power of Slavic
folklore lasted a long time and it can
tell us a lot about how the Slav saw the
world around them but Lesya has become
less popular over time perhaps because
the lessons he teaches are no longer as
relevant as the forests have been
cleared and rural Slavic life became
less common
while the ritual is associated with the
Guardian and demon of the forest Windell
the idea of him does appear in popular
culture now and again despite what they
may tell you Alessi is both a guardian
and an Avenger since I know you've spent
some time over in Russia and you've done
a lot of work with some of these you
know native language tax do you still
think or have you encountered people who
still believe in the lies she doesn't
have her surname or last like 20 or 30
years which is a way of people I can go
to get in touch with their own their own
country that history they're all against
it definitely there's ton of
superstition in Russia it's probably
probably the country that loves
superstition or most of any place I've
traveled that that can mean like
unmarried women can't giving Guardian
it's not somebody who believed in I
think more people who won't like power
of me so I believing that the forest
times has a presence on a life and
community there's certain real and alive
and present
well neither good nor evil this
forest-dwelling shapeshifter was scary
because it could be lurking around every
corner the less she represents a deep
respect for the forest and acknowledges
the dangers humans encountered there
especially when it was largely untamed
it was something that could only be
avoided with caution awareness and a
sincere appreciation of your
surroundings the moral of the story
be nice to nature you never know when a
giant forest spirit will come for you
yeah KK but say a lot reference anyone
Bueller